il bullismo è un fenomeno molto diffuso
più diffuso di quello che noi
pensiamo
secondo il ministero
della pubblica istruzione
su uno studio fatto appunto nel 2020 nel
2021 su un campione di 300 14.500
studenti hanno scoperto che il 22,3 per
cento degli studenti dichiara di essere
vittima di bullismo il 18,2 per cento
dichiara di aver preso parte attivamente
al fenomeno del bullismo e il 7 per
cento dichiara di aver preso parte a
episodi di cyberbullismo ed è per questo
che io al 9 di febbraio del 2015 mi sono
un po messo in gioco e ho deciso di
fondare un'associazione di volontariato
che si occupa proprio di bullismo di
cyber bullismo che si chiama a cbs
associazione di volontariato contro il
bullismo scolastico ho deciso di
fondarla perché io stesso ho subito
bullismo e cyberbullismo per tutto il
mio percorso scolastico quindi per 13
anni circa
oggi fortunatamente si parla tanto di
questo fenomeno se ne sta parlando anche
tanto e come ogni cosa quando si parla
tanto di un fenomeno purtroppo si parla
anche male di solito quando si parla di
bullismo zidane si dice che il bullismo
è tutto no anche i giornali le
televisioni dicono bullo rapina una
banca ma realtà non è così il bullismo
ha un significato tutto suo ed è
particolare anche se può sembrare
una parola molto semplice da capire ma
ha un suo significato per essere
considerato bullismo deve avere tre
caratteristiche fondamentali il primo è
l'intenzionalità il bullo o la bulla è
una persona sono le persone molto
intelligenti ho detto anche bulla perché
il bullismo femminile è diffuso quanto
quello maschile io stesso subito più
bullismo femminile che maschile no sono
delle persone molto intelligenti
studiano la propria vittima sanno che
possono andare da lui o da lei possono
fare tutto quello che vogliono senza
ricevere nulla in cambio perché sanno
che la vittima non ha il coraggio di
fare ciò che
loro fanno con lei no la seconda
caratteristica la persistenza il bullo
continua e non si stancava avanti
all'infinito e quando una vittima decide
di parlare 16 di riparlare sceglie di
raccontare l'episodio meno grave chi si
è mai capitato io andavo dal prof ricevo
prof guardi mi hanno rubato alla
bottiglietta d'acqua e il prof e diceva
ma se andiamo alla macchinetta traete la
vado a prendere io no ma nessuno ha mai
si è mai domandato che col mio grido
d'aiuto era perché dietro si nascondeva
l'altro la terza caratteristica è la
simmetria della relazione che cosa
significa che il bullo per
caratteristiche fisiche per età o per
carattere
non è si sente più grande della vittima
non se la prenderebbe mai con un suo
simile perché dietro ci sono delle
persone che lo sostengono
oggi purtroppo esistono diverse forme di
bullismo io nella vita non mi sono mai
fatto mancare niente li ho subiti tutti
quanti il primo è il bullismo fisico e
quello che se parliamo con i nostri
genitori con i nostri nonni ci dicono e
quello che è sempre esistito già dal
militare no in questa tipologia di
bullismo tu conosci quello che hai
davanti sai chi ti sta facendo del male
e si ha il coraggio di parlare
sai chi è il nome il cognome della
persona che si sta facendo del male
la seconda tipologia il verbale quello
che tutti dicono sono gli scherzi le
offese anche in questa tipologia di
bullismo chi lo subisce sacchi ha
davanti e può riconoscerlo sa nome e
cognome quindi lo vede lo sente e sia
decide di parlare sa come fare
sul cyberbullismo diciamo che ci
vorrebbe un sacco di tempo oggi
oggi siamo tutti quanti con un telefono
tutti siamo sui social lo smartphone era
lo strumento che veniva regalato ai
ragazzi quando compivano i 18 anni no
poi piano piano le tasse scesa hanno
iniziato i genitori a darlo alla alla
cresima
poi la comunione poi alla confessione
speriamo che non sarà il regalo del
battesimo perché altrimenti la
situazione veramente molto più
preoccupante io avevo l'ansia della
domenica pomeriggio che cosa significa
che io quando tornavo a casa il venerdì
da scuola ero contento perché c'era la
weekend e quindi
arrivava la domenica era domenica
pomeriggio avevo l'ansia perché dicevo
caspita
domani si va a scuola e quindi avevo
questa paura i ragazzi quest'ansia chi è
super tutto subisce cyberbullismo ce
l'ha sempre perché oggi io sono qui a
chilometri di distanza da casa mia posso
bersagliare chi voglio in questo preciso
momento quindi oggi non c'è spazio non
c'è tempo i ragazzi subiscono 24 ore su
24 e non solo a scuola ma in qualsiasi
parte del mondo
per l'ultima categoria vi devo fare
degli esempi perché diciamo che a
differenza di quelle precedenti dove tu
conosci il nome e cognome delle persone
qui non ha il nome e cognome qui è tutto
il contesto e facciamo un esempio
facciamo finta che adesso sono le otto
del mattino che stiamo entrando in
classe
saluti tuoi compagni di classe nessuno e
nessuno ti ricambia il saluto facciamo
finta che siamo in palestra che il prof
e dice dividetevi per squadre tu sia di
chi aspetti il tuo nome e non arriva mai
e quando arriva per ultimo i compagni
classico non fa abbiamo lui oggi
sicuramente perdiamo organizzano feste
di compleanno e lo sa il giorno dopo
organizzano compiti si vedono
tu sei lì in classe vedi gente felice e
non tu questo che vi ho raccontato sono
stati gli ultimi tre anni della mia
scuola superiore e quando un ragazzo
subisce quasi tipologia di bullismo chi
non ha il nome e cognome tutto il
contesto è tutta la classe che ti fa
credere che tu sei il problema e tu che
cosa fai o scappi
o diventi come loro oresti quello che se
io ho deciso di rimanere quello che ero
il vincenzo di qualche anno fa lo stesso
di quello di oggi perché io non mi sono
mai sottomesso al gruppo e vi dico che
non è facile
ma cosa bisogna fare come riconoscere
una situazione di bullismo questo è
quello che cerco
cerco di spiegare il più possibile chi
sono principalmente i protagonisti
perché di solito tutti parlano della
vittima
parlano del bullo ma nessuno prende mai
in considerazione gli spetta il bullo è
quello che fa l'atto la vittima quello
che la subisce
ma gli spettatori sono coloro che
possono cambiare l'andamento della
situazione sono coloro che quando
vengono interpellati dal prof dicono no
però che non ho visto niente se l'è
cercata è colpa sua
oppure sono coloro che leggono il
messaggio su sulla chat e non
intervengono sono quelli che non sanno
mai nulla
gli spettatori sono coloro che possono
cambiare veramente l'andamento della
situazione
io da ex vittima vi dico una cosa è
strano sei un ex vittima dice una cosa
del genere ma io ci tengo io non
considero il bullo bullo io considero
bullo una vittima di una situazione di
una di un'educazione e di un sistema
totalmente sbagliato e corrotto io
considero bullo gli spettatori che sono
coloro che potevano darvi una mano sono
erano coloro che potevano aiutare e sono
coloro che possano aiutare che subisce
bullismo ma tendenzialmente non fanno
mai nulla bisogna lavorare tanto su di
loro e l'indifferenza e roberta la
scuola è veramente all'ordine del giorno
ai ragazzi scelgono di cambiare scuola
perché se non si sentono all'interno del
gruppo
e se il gruppo non collabora la vittima
sceglie sempre strade alternative
ed è per questo motivo che io durante il
periodo dell'occhio dow iniziato un po a
vedere un po di cose no ho iniziato a
vedere delle fotografie ho iniziato a
studiare un po il mio passato perché
avevo un po di tempo e dalle fotografie
di classe ho iniziato a trovare delle
caratteristiche comuni che io avevo su
ogni fotografia di classe che osservavo
ed è per questo che vi dico che la
comunicazione non verbale è molto molto
importante specialmente quando vi
trovate a in una situazione in cui la
vittima non parla il bullo non parla e
gli spettatori che cosa fanno non
parlano e lì mi sono posto il problema
ho detto ma come possiamo noi adulti
scoprire se un ragazzo sta subendo
bullismo se tutti quanti sono zitti
omertosi
ed è appunto per questo che osservando
un po le fotografie di classe
ho visto dalle particolarità
io sono colui che qui è cerchiato di
rosso e come potete vedere io ero di
fianco al professore con la mano in
tasca vestito diverso dagli altri e
questa foto è questa caratteristica ce
l'avevo praticamente in ogni singola
fotografia
e da lì poi ho guardato su internet
altre fotografie di classe di altre
persone sconosciute ed ho visto che di
solito che vittima si pone ad un passo
staccato dal gruppo di solito si mette
vicino a un docente
perché non si sente appartenente a quel
nucleo quella classe no io tutte le mie
fotografie di classe sono così e ho
detto caspita ma perché non divulgarla
questa cosa no ed è per questo che io
sono qui oggi io nella vita sono sempre
stato l'ultimo sia sia per nome che per
cognome che per le scelte che ho fatto
anche a scuola perché alla fine
come dire nell'elenco ero sempre
l'ultimo vetere vincenziano sempre
l'ultimo
malessere ultimo mi ha dato la
possibilità di sedermi
vedere le persone dall alto verso dal
basso verso l'alto e di non commettere
gli errori che hanno fatto loro e oggi
sono qui anche perché voglio farmi un po
da portavoce a tutti di tutti quei
ragazzi che ancora oggi subiscono
bullismo e non hanno avuto ancora il
coraggio di parlarne
sono un po emozionato scusatemi ma
grazie
spero in un giorno di chiudere tutto
quello che ho fatto perché se chiude
un'associazione come la nostra
significa che non ci sarà più bisogno di
noi io vi ringrazio e spero di rivedervi
presto grazie a tutti